[Música]
desde el inicio de la operación
lavalleto contra la corrupción en 2014
la imagen del expresidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva representado como un preso
ha sido una constante las
manifestaciones del partido de los
trabajadores
la consolidación del bolsonarismo fue
cual ayudada por el profundo
antipatitismo es decir el odio hacia
este partido de una parte de la
población desde 1994 este funcionario
público votó a Lula en todas las
elecciones presidenciales hasta que se
decepcionó con el líder de la izquierda
dice que fue por su sed de poder
yo estoy contra el PT por causa de la
corrupción generalizada y la falta de
competencia Hoy vemos Un gobierno que
escogió cargos técnicos muchos de ellos
no han ido bien pero no hubo
nombramientos partidarios con el PT los
nombramientos no transmitían una
seguridad técnica
el rechazo Lula está muy presente entre
las clases medias y las profesiones
liberales que apoyan el programa
económico de bolsonaro
es el caso de esta arquitecta que ve con
buenos ojos que haya más privatizaciones
y menos presencia del Estado
hagan a las elecciones en mi opinión
será un gran retroceso para Brasil
porque él va a empezar a colocar
impuestos chiítas en todo y Brasil no se
va a desarrollar
[Música]
el negocio de Denise mejoró durante la
gestión de bolsonaro lo que ha reforzado
su repudio hacia un tercer gobierno de
Lula yo en este momento siento vergüenza
Del Noroeste ustedes nacieron para vivir
de subsidios durante la campaña
electoral el antipismo derivado en la
xenofobia sobre todo en las redes
sociales
tradicionalmente una triunfa en todos
los estados del noroeste la región más
pobre de Brasil de la que emigran
trabajadores desempleados hacia el sur
Lula ganó el 9 de los 10 estados con
mayor tasa de analfabetismo Sabes cuáles
son estos es nuestro Noreste
incluso evolucionaron arremetió contra
los nordestinos después de la primera
vuelta como Suele suceder esto no ha
mermado el apoyo de sus seguidores